on va parler de cinéma à présent dans le
7 8 d'habitude c'est plutôt le mercredi
jour de sortie dans les salles de cinéma
que l'on aborde ce sujet mais demain
débute bien sûr cette 76e édition du
Festival de Cannes qui va se dérouler
donc du 16 au 27 mai sur la Croisette
grande fête du cinéma est-ce que vous
êtes passionné Gabriel de cinéma
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire le
Festival de Cannes incontournable
forcément c'est beaucoup de symboles
beaucoup de stars qui font le
déplacement et puis je crois que malgré
les années il y a toujours le même
engouement si ce n'est plus autour du
cinéma et encore plus après le covid
avec une édition en plus qui avait été
qui avait été annulé on en parle
justement avec Gauthier Bara qui est
avec nous depuis le début de cette
édition réalisateur producteur yvelinois
installé à Buc en ce moment alors vous
nous disiez tout à l'heure pourquoi
c'était intéressant et pourquoi vous
aviez un intérêt chaque année à suivre
ce festival de Cannes vous vous y rendez
aussi régulièrement environ tous les
deux ans je le disais tout à l'heure 21
films en compétition dans la sélection
officielle de ce 76e Festival de Cannes
est-ce que ça s'annonce être un bon
festival un bon cru cette année selon
vous bah oui parce que j'ai regardé un
peu la liste et il y a autant enfin
comme d'habitude en fait des films
asiatiques des films étrangers on a
plusieurs films français alors pas que
forcément sur la catégorie principale on
a la catégorie Un Certain Regard moi sur
lequel j'ai un très grand regard parce
qu'en fait c'est là où il y avait un
film un réalisateur qui avait fait
snoothie que j'avais beaucoup aimé et
derrière il nous a fait deux palmes d'or
qui était en compétition officielle donc
c'est ne pas négliger alors il y a la
sélection officielle c'est vrai sur
laquelle et le feu de tous les
projecteurs enfin voilà tous les
projecteurs sont sont braqués mais il
faut aussi justement la catégorie
attentive sur les autres catégories et
un certain regard je trouve que des fois
c'est
plus pertinent que la catégorie
officielle parce qu'on a vraiment des
films qui sortent du lot avec pas
forcément des acteurs connus et
on est mais bouche bée devant donc voilà
alors on va regarder la fiche de cette
76e édition qui vous allez le voir dans
une image noir et blanc mettant lumière
Catherine Deneuve on a eu très récemment
Agnès Varda avec sa disparition qui
avait été mise à l'honneur au Festival
de Cannes Pierrot le Fou et Jean-Paul
Belmondo qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire
Gautier baral à cette cette belle
affiche de de Catherine Deneuve affiche
en noir et blanc
le noir et blanc rajoute déjà le le
petit côté rappel de du lancement du
cinéma donc c'est hyper intéressant
je vais en parler parce que il y a un
film qui me plaît dans la catégorie qui
s'appelle may Defender qui fait partie
donc c'est de ces 21 film en sélection
officielle et qui traite beaucoup de la
femme et c'est vrai que pendant pas mal
d'années de plus en plus sur les
affiches du Festival de Cannes on a
quand même de plus en plus de femmes
présentes et c'est important ça c'est
une bonne chose ça commence à enfin à
bien bouger ça de manière générale on
peut même le voir sur les grandes
plateformes connues comme Netflix la
place aussi de la des acteurs de
couleurs qui arrivent de plus en plus
sur le devant de la scène et c'est un
pas qui se fait délicatement et
proprement et aujourd'hui on tout
doucement on enlève ces ces mauvaises
mœurs et on laisse place donc là aux
femmes aux gens qu'on n'a pas l'habitude
de voir à l'écran et c'est très sympa et
donc le film qui a réalisé par totens
et Carole je crois aussi donc il y a
Nathalie Portman et Julian Moore donc
ils sont quand même deux grandes femmes
qui qui ont bien percé par elle-même et
ça traite un peu du cinéma dans le
cinéma donc c'est c'est l'histoire d'une
jeune enfin du d'une femme qui a une
carrière qui va être interprétée au
cinéma par une autre femme et ça va être
la rencontre entre ces deux personnes
qui auront des points de vue je pense
différents je n'ai pas encore vu le film
mais
enfin voilà de d'une star et d'une
personne en dessous qui va devoir
interpréter discuter je pense
voir un peu comment la personne vivait
les choses comment elle les a senti tout
au long de sa carrière et tout et tout
donc je pense que c'est encore un sujet
très intéressant et je pense qui peut
souvent ce type de film remporter des
prix d'un point de vue comédienne donc
ce sera à surveiller pour mettre
dissender de tonnes vous l'avez
sélectionné parce que il fait la part
belle aux femmes justement un
rendez-vous qu'on aussi au Festival de
Cannes c'est le film en ouverture cette
année ce film en ouverture ce sera gêne
du Barry de Maïwenn justement une
réalisatrice française qui est mise à
l'honneur avec au casting Johnny Depp
pour pour le citer des images en plus
qui ont été tournées à Versailles
tournez dans les Yvelines c'est ça
j'ai pu entre guillemets
en fait je me baladais dans Versailles
et bien évidemment bah on croisait
toutes les caravanes de tournage tous
les cette année il y a eu enfin sur les
deux dernières années beaucoup beaucoup
de films qui ont été présents enfin sur
à tourner à Versailles je crois qu'on a
eu novembre qui avait été tourné avec
Jean Dujardin à Versailles et ça
s'enchaîne pas mal on a deux trois
séries Netflix aussi qui sont tournés à
Versailles donc ça commence à bien
porter ses fruits là le casting a l'air
très intéressant le sujet est
intéressant madame Dubarry et en
fermeture je crois du Festival de Cannes
on a ce qui est rare un dessin animé
je crois qu'il s'appelle élément de
Paris sur les éléments de Disney
qui a l'air très mignon donc l'âme
d'enfants ressort de de l'âme mais je
pense que qui peut être très touchant et
émouvant un peu à la vice Versailles
projection durant le festival du dernier
opus on a la première d'Indiana Jones
voilà on est on navigue entre différents
styles dans ce festival de Cannes je
voulais juste vous faire dire un mot sur
le jury qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire en
prison du jury à Rouben osloon a le
réalisateur suédois on retrouve aussi un
yvelinois dans ce casting avec Denis
menochet qui est on a vu notamment dans
une glorious Basters mais dans d'autres
films également qu'est-ce que ça vous
inspire ce ce jury du Festival de
casting de ce jury et ben justement le
le Président
c'est celui qui a fait sonothérapie donc
j'ai parlé juste avant qui a eu ces deux
palmes
Square et et après c'était sans filtre
et ben j'apprécie énormément sur les là
on a pu le croiser il y a pas longtemps
au Chesnay pour une projection de
saint-filtre en avant-première donc
enfin c'est là on voit que le cinéma en
fait
c'est un peu plus que que un écran de
télévision parce que
les gens viennent vers nous c'est à dire
que ça ne s'arrête pas et je trouve de
plus en plus aujourd'hui c'est à dire
qu'on a on a des Américains qui viennent
enfin le Grand Rex ça fait une grande
ouverture là dessus le nombre de films
américains étrangers qui viennent
présenter en avant-première leur film en
France c'est de plus en plus intéressant
et de plus en plus favorisant ton pays
en plus de collaboration entre les pays
en plus je crois avoir compris que
Johnny Depp aujourd'hui mais énormément
l'accueil des français ici et je crois
est en train de prévoir ils ont annoncé
ça il y a quelques jours un futur film
réalisé par Johnny Depp avec Pierre
Niney et Al Pacino c'est le strass et
les paillettes et vous le disiez tout à
l'heure pour les professionnels du
cinéma si une opportunité incroyable de
se rencontrer d'essayer aussi de vendre
leurs production il y a un marché du
film Un directement implanté au sein du
Palais des Festivals vous c'est cette
occasion là que vous vous saisissez tous
les deux ans c'est de se rendre pour
faire du du business autour du film si
je puis dire parce que il y a le stress
et les paillettes il y a tout le marché
du film c'est ça en fait la toute
première année où je suis allé au
Festival de Cannes donc j'étais déjà
encore en école de cinéma
il faut savoir que sur deux semaines de
festival enfin je crois c'est 10 jours
on dit la quinzaine plutôt sur des gens
j'ai dû voir je crois 28 ou 30 films
voilà sur une petite semaine parce qu'on
y était pas là en intégralité et en fait
plus années passent moins j'ai le temps
de voir de film
et tout simplement parce que
tout se passe on va dire dans les
coulisses du festival de Cannes on
rencontre les gens sur les des terrasses
il faut un peu s'infiltrer dans dans des
bâtiments un peu prestigieux comme le
carton le Majestic ou encore le soir sur
des invitations un peu privées ou dans
des villas ou sur des bateaux et c'est
là où on rencontre on discute un peu
ouvertement d'un point de vue naturel
d'autres producteurs d'autres acteurs et
on parle de nos projets et on essaye un
peu de vendre nos futurs projets qui
sont à l'avenir ou encore des projets
qu'on a fait pour les distribuer
justement alors petite petite question
non vous aviez une question vous me
tendez la terre justement sur les futurs
projets peut-être que vous allez
l'occasion d'en parler dans un prochain
Festival de Cannes le monstre de la
vallée qui est votre de votre
réalisation écrit par Jérémy Caen
production kn5 productions et le
chanteur Mata au casting et Damien
Carion et Alain Inizan parlez-nous en où
est-ce qu'on en est ce que ce film va
est déjà disponible ce qui va bientôt
sortir alors le film on a fini le
tourner il y a un peu moins de deux
semaines donc il est tout frais on voit
quelques images en avant-première sur
sur TV 78 et vous avez de la chance
parce que c'est la première fois qu'on
sort des images
donc voilà donc on a tourné ça dans
différents lieux yvinois on a tourné ça
un raid moulin
à Bailly à Noisy-le-Roi donc vraiment ce
sont des des villes un peu on va dire de
mon enfance parce que j'ai vécu dans ce
point là pendant plus de 10 ans et
donc le film en fait traite un peu
ça me fait penser un peu du coup
justement président du jury qui avait
fait pas mal de choses comme ça
la différence entre
la limite on va dire de l'humain à
travers la limite de l'art ici moi je
parle plutôt de
le monstre qui est le véritable monstre
parce que c'est l'animal ou est-ce que
c'est l'humain voilà on va revenir sur
le titre phare la bête humaine mais
voilà donc ça traite beaucoup de ça on
parle un peu d'écologie dedans surtout
sur toute la première surtout sur toute
la première partie du film
ça a été un film pour moi un peu
complexe à tourner du fait que
sur le fait qu'on a beaucoup tourné de
nuit bon ça je suis habitué mais on
faisait quand même des nuits blanches du
19h jusqu'à jusqu'au lever du soleil
donc on jusqu'à 5 6 heures du matin et
c'est surtout qu'on a fait un test pour
moi qui était important c'est on a dû
tourner sous la pluie
ils avaient annoncé de la pluie sauf
qu'on a eu zéro gouttes et on a tourné
sous une fausse pluie d'accord donc
première c'était une première pour moi
et
ça a été très difficile pour les
comédiens d'ailleurs on avait aussi un
tout petit jeune d'une Raphaël qui était
présent et qui est qui s'est donné à
100% et qui d'ailleurs va préparer des
nouveaux films qu'on va voir sur grand
écran au cinéma très prochainement mais
ils ont tout donné et que ça soit pour
nous comme pour eux c'était difficile et
le résultat est très très beau il sera
que vous avez vu quelques images
pour la fin de l'année je pense faire
des projections sur Versailles noisy
Bali
assez rapidement on va sortir peut-être
une bande-annonce avant l'été voilà bon
ben merci Gauthier Barat d'être venu
parler de tous ces sujets à votre
prochain film le monstre de la vallée
bien sûr l'ouverture ce 76e Festival de
Cannes ouverture demain et c'est donc
jusqu'au 27 mai sur la Croisette on vous
fera vivre de l'intérieur cette 77e
édition au travers de reportages qui
seront proposés par nos confrères de
radio sensation